blog numero 21 iniziamo ad annusare il
traguardo di questo terzo anno di fila
diplomacy questore non è mai stato così
buono enrico sta passando un tram non
farti uccidere per favore chi ci segue
da un po saprà che quasi un anno che
praticamente noi collaboriamo con
philadelphia siamo alle nostre nozze
d'argento a questo punto per cui quello
che faremo oggi sarà preparare una sorta
di renata le compagnie di philadelphia
anche perché mi sa che sto natale e poi
una mezza busta che fare quindi finché
stiamo insieme abbiamo deciso di gioire
qualsiasi momento passato in compagnia
anche perché lo so ora capo manderà un
sera che i primi due giorni sono tipo se
me ne sono liberato finalmente che poi
chiudi mancate stupida emotività prima
di andare però al supermercato ho deciso
di portare burdo a fare veramente un
saluto alla sua fidanzata se ci avesse
la troviamo oggi è morta lei lei diciamo
conservasse dire due volte ma in realtà
è una profumiera è una forma di amore
settembrino
non abbiamo ancora capito dove stanno i
supermercati o almeno quelli più forniti
quindi quello che farò sarà andare
dentro questo e spera di trovare tutto
quello che mi serve perché quello con
gabriele era lontanissimo e non
io torno per rimanere con culto tra poco
lentissimo marcello stiamo marciando la
muffa
stiamo facendo la muffa ancora niente
quanto ci vorrà comprare la vicenda
abbiamo visto passare in migliaia di
persone stiamo studiando tutta la
popolazione locale ma non è che c'è in
uscita sul retro e quello è scappato dal
retro attraverso un uscita dal retro a
velocità di test in vitro il bastardo
che era sulla sua lentezza incredibile
che prema che ha lentissimo potrà stare
a pensioni e lento ancora che torna su
questa via maledetto di nuovo la rifatta
questa scena è un doppione di elmo mi ha
fatto un cenno di abbagli pure a dare
una mano oppure ha comprato tutto con
prodotto non senti stiamo aspettando da
supermercati sono tipo la mappa del
malandrino che si capisce dove andare
mancano ancora tre ingredienti per
rendere movimento a neto è un uomo del
luogo di lombardo ce frega dai scriviamo
sotto nei commenti servono no ok
un altro che vestiti ci porta ma perché
preso un pandoro 2 volte 1 in realtà
aveva lo champagne dentro non avevo
visto che c'era quello lì senza lo
champagne e quindi ho preso quello di
senso champagne a cassano magnago rino
prima di girare abbiamo deciso di fare
un assaggino va bene ma che vuoi tu non
sei mia madre non puoi tre parti senza
contare che appena saputo che s'è
mangiata per darmi anche dei consigli di
cucina è venuta spreco tampone giulia
per la non vedenti in fondo di via di
qui a sinistra
ora visto che seguì da qua devi comunque
aiutarci con le faccende da casa ma
fanno satira come in più per colpire ma
mia sorella non sono un fan del blues
del piede piani e le gocce di cioccolato
fondente
allora io gli farò dei rotolini di
salmone ancora rabbia e poi la stella di
mare che pandoro altro che il brunch di
valentino
[Applauso]
niente che legava le beta che sia chiaro
questo punto mi trovo a dedicare del
calendario delle ricette che si trova
sul sito www.style.it manie realta io ho
preso ispirazione ma questi piatti visto
anche adattando la mia presa di
coloriamo ci sto facendo un po
l'anarchico lecce camere 20 reti perché
philadelphia e tutti il adelfia e
camaleontico philadelphia è dolce e
salato questo qui è la prima cosa che vi
invito a fare tutti quanti perché la
fate in due secondi proprio prova di un
lido di latina prova della linea
prendete le fette di salmone vedere come
sto facendo e le apro perbene
separandole sanzaro per le mi raccomando
siamo certi un procedimento in più bene
tutti e solare guardami sopetti gli
avocado ovunque il piacere vedere un
volto nuovo prima di questa casa ti
avrei odiato al invece adesso
a bilanciare che sto facendo io ho preso
il filadelfia e lo storia in realtà
lavorando all'interno della sua stessa
confezione modo da evitare di sporcare
altre cose non voglio dire raggiungo un
pochino di limone un pochino di sale
lavorate il succo di limone il sale
nella philadelphia e a questo punto
avrete vedete una spugnosità per cui
sarà più facile spalmarla con
delicatezza sopra le nostre fette di
salmone questo che può facile ragazzi
siamo facendo roba veloce risi per uno
stuzzichino sfizioso questo è un ottimo
antipasto secondo me palladino la verità
però è chiara da detta chiara ma c'e una
mia cara amica quindi non si arrabbierà
se dico che non è vero che lei ha
suggerito queste cose in realtà io l'ho
suggerite a lei e sono sicuro che anche
lei dopo un bonifico dire alla stessa
cosa anche le fette piccole e poi potete
prenderle e mangia non c'è nessuno
renata poco dire che sembra suscita
cedere io adesso sembra sullo sci prendi
in giro
tripi e in dentro questa parte a questo
punto giri branding ribalti su se stessa
gigi di giri e fomentare poi se acino
per riposare trattamento in frigo perché
così il filadelfia e riprende corposità
e quel punto poi affettare meglio fare
le ronde nella rete sui crostini brusca
ti quindi accendete mi portò al volo in
frigo a questo punto andiamo a pescare
velocemente di padre entrò più di quanto
fin che segue sono un pochino quelle
ricette facili né vogliono anche devi
stare proprio appresso l'acqua la
bilancia a meno che non carboni zipa le
boe si spera che questo 1 riesca a
gestirlo da solo si deve durare il pane
e ad alberello aumenta al fumetto a fumi
e avicola però aspetta guarda chi è che
lo dovrebbe fare io sto per insegnare la
ricetta per la crema segreta di
guglielmo che in realtà rubato a sua
volta da un sito internet ovunque la
retti trasforma qualsiasi cosa nel dolce
pd non esiste
ve lo giuro che è quella che metto pure
te darren helm entrare sia sulla
ringhiera ragazzi chiarezza lavorato
prima di fare qualsiasi cosa giusto
giuliano per a fare una cannelle di
philadelphia con branca cocito subito
quando tu prendi cucchiani a e poi fai
da te e poi mela lanci in bocca
direttamente noi hanno ancora di grande
marilungo s riderà zuccherare che ha
detto ragazzi milano bucchieri non è
stato sfruttato assaggiare per me così è
per fermarmi guadagna sfuma signori
marco mentito che una grattugia d'errore
gentilmente grazie mille
[Musica]
ma ieri guardando però più un oggetto è
stata gelata o non è bruciato questo
padre di baladin l'avevo detto
raga io non sono un fan del limone ma
qui si sta via proprio una freschezza
che ciò che avete fatto
philadelphia zucchero a velo scossoni
fino finito per realizzare questo
effetto
mi raccomando mettete in forno spalato
sono sopra cottage e niente ma che
camicie in fondo così in cantina
siciliana è presente la valentina ma
anche con competenze è però stato giusto
dove la mamma mia da qui ha un'altra
faccia come fa fare da controllare
importantissimo incontro alla valle in
al controllo vale granché contro linee
perfette ragazzi ragazzi questo il
momento della stella di pandoro ragazzi
silenzio non dedicate a un incisione poi
in realtà noi ne facciamo una madre
possono fare di più e sempre tutti
quanti dico costellazione in qualche
modo fette spesse già di per sé opera
d'arte quello che faccio io è la tetta e
così impari giro in modo le faccia di
perfetto coppetta perché non si è più
superficie non vorrebbero andare a letto
invece di avere meno superficie lo vedo
giulia che passi con la tesi
oman d'oro al contrario una sac à poche
ma a questo punto io vado ma che bravo
ragazzo perché non sapendo di fare un
buon in questo modo fratino e se ha
voluto valentina io me ne vada giulia
veramente ci ha dato lo strumento gioia
una gioia dubbi cioè tu sei la star che
questo canale merito a questo punto
mirtilli la linea del relatore a
verificare se foste breve che mi ricorda
un po la lega
in realtà ci sarebbero da dio le
foglioline di menta ma non le abbiamo
trovate ad un supermercato quindi sto
rosicando come poca cosa al mondo giulia
che ne dici di aggiungerci anche delle
scaglie di cioccolato prende il coltello
è però della segatura di cioccolato solo
al centro ma wow segatura di gioco
sapete che cosa è un altro nata a
mandorla e ma che bel castello idoli
inferi con così la facciamo termine
tecnico ma sono orgogliosissimo ragazzi
se fate il pandoro pagateci su instagram
fateci vedere le nostre costruzioni pane
in cassetta abbruscato che ora
dall'altro lato perché vedere una cosa
avevo fatto bene facciamo molte veroli
hanno preso di farine diverse modo anche
di avere un pochino di colore sul piatto
che stai facendo presente coi meme dei
teschi e questo e dopo 20 del passaggio
ridi vlog mangiato di nascosto neanche
loro bloccando esso sfondato tutto
quanto 1 philadelphia si rimanga trani
va beh se saremo sbagliati enrico ii un
bel taglio per rosso di che stereo hi
tempistiche del brunch ed è valentina
vedo con stupore che ai fini ci volevo
fare un albero di natale sembra un
granchio delle bellissime borse non ho
avuto manualità giusto ea come ad
ottenere infatti a casa così i mercati
sapete cosa si fa in questi casi questo
qui è una cosa che invece di insegna a
tutti quanti a salvare in una situazione
che effettivamente emergenza emergenza
ok non sono stato molto capace avvocato
due anziché mettendo un po di topi con
l'avvocato allora diversa bellissima non
mi sembra un albero di natale e natale
club di soia cosa intendi pare sembra
tipo sushi buono molto buono non 3 così
fresco nuova per luigi aver preso numero
un cappello al pane croccante stati
arresti a sopra molto buono anche
gianmarco anche se non ami il salmone
affumicato
assaggiate tutti vede attivi voglio
vedere le vostre facce mentre assaggiate
fondamentale perché è durato 300.000
vasetti philadelphia a banco alimentare
per aiutare a dare una mano tutte quante
300 mila e 100 mila per dare una mano a
tutte quante le famiglie le persone in
difficoltà con questo periodo
l'iniziativa bellissima ci tenevo
particolarmente a dire bravi è un
piacere per noi parlare di voi
soprattutto mangiamo quelle
si no sì perché abbiamo già dato che è
meglio che vai rimane signore dare
accomodate viene dal caffè nella ripresa
cui tempo che si è preso la vetta grazie
poi a di sfigati ragazzi arrivati alla
fine di questa giornata passata in
realtà sfamarci il mangiare cucinare mi
mancava un po come cosa anche perché
sono gli ultimissimi giorni gli vlog
massai rimbalziamo sempre da una parte
all'altra non ci fermiamo mai un istante
anche di avere anche la scusa per poter
stare veramente tutti quanti insieme in
cucina scherzare a ridere in fatto molto
piacere tutto questo video ringraziano
ancora philadelphia ringraziato tutti
quanti modi anche ringraziando i ragazzi
stanno in casa con me perché anche se
sono arrivato un momento nel quale b di
harley è come vedere ogni volta una
presenza horror all'interno della tua
abitazione
gli voglio bene un bacio e ci vediamo
domani con il terzultimo